ahmed avec ta ta ta ta [ __ ] ouais
j'avais une petite c'est la maman de
maurice blamont à et donc tous les
après-midi tous les mercredis après-midi
reçoit ses amis ses deux copines elles
sont trois cd ami de longue date qu
elles sont tranquilles voilà les dates
entre son équipe et est donc tous les
tous les mercredis elles font points
comme ça et là tu as la première maman
qui dit mon fils du béni s'il a fait une
année je te jure je te raconte pas ça
rajouter à ce qu'ils avaient déjà je te
jure elle est tellement riche il peut
acheter paris tranquille la deuxième
regarde comme ça et bien a bon bah tu
sais que moi il a ça fait deux années de
suite il écarte on plaît il et cartons
pleins laisse tomber c'est à dire que
moi mon fils il veut demain ils achètent
paris new york avec y rajoute new york
qui lui reste de la monique il atteint
la troisième qui dit et pardon les
filles qui vous a dit que mon fils
voulait vendre
moyens bien sûr c'est maurice benhamou
qui est avec vous les laisse à toi c moi
les bénévoles avec son ami jean baptiste
et jean mathis suis dit c'est maurice
j'ai un super plan écoute tu peux manger
à l'oeil au resto comme ça tu peux
manger à l'oeil au restaurant comment tu
fais tu écoutes c'est très simple tu vas
tu jean tu restes à table jusqu'à la
fermeture du restaurant une fois que le
patron te demande de régler tu dis que
tu as déjà réglé avec un serveur
égyptien que c'est exceptionnel que sac
à main comme comme comme un com com
comme technique c'est incroyable ça sent
bon resto ce soir là tu montre comment
faire
c'est un problème avec plaisir ils vont
dîner au resto tous les deux comme ça
entrée plat dessert fromage soit un
petit verre à la fin cognac au top ils
passent la soirée s'allume un cigare
mauricie au top il kiffe sa soirée et
d'abandonner le patron du restaurant une
fois que toutes les parties qu'il dit
excusez moi monsieur
on va faire mais est-ce que je vous
pouvez me régler s'il vous plaît et
l'ail jean baptiste qui dit mme excusez
moi mais on a déjà réglé avec un serveur
qui est parti désolé l'amour est-il dit
ouais excusez moi et on attend la
monnaie [ __ ] à l'horaire
[Applaudissements]